hi
i'm daniel and today i'll talk about um
dynamic pricing with bandits which is a
use case that we've been working on at
fiber
daniel and data scientist at fiber
alongside me we have uri
which i believe most of you already know
cool so agenda for today we'll start
with a brief overview about what fiber
is
what do we do then we'll dive into some
business use case or specific use case
which will focus on the ad side on the
advertiser side
we'll then uh have a deep dive on the
main challenges
that a bidder and advertiser focuses on
then we'll
go into a more detailed specific use
case of this
of this session which is common
approaches to pricing
we'll dive into contextual bandits which
is the main topic and the main thing we
actually
took to to investigate and research
about wrap up with some key takeaways
and then we'll have a coding example
uh which uri will present some code that
we actually worked on
so we'll be able to see something that
in hand
cool fiber overview so fiber
how many of you here know fiber
nice not too much but cool fiber is an
at the company dealing in the space of
mobile mostly as opposed to for example
tabula
most am works mostly on web so we're
dealing in the space between publishers
which are app developers
and advertisers and connecting between
both
via rtb real-time bidding for those who
know
we're a global company most of the
employees are like tech
meaning we're a very tech company rnd
product
um and yep that's like the slide that
actually describes the scale of our data
not sure it's the scale of tabula's data
but still
basically we're talking about 40 billion
auctions per day and an auction will
describe what it is in a bit
thousands of applications being
integrated via our platform and we have
like
a lot of we can say dimensions and
metrics we can you to which you can
slice and dice the data and analyze
accordingly
tons of uh yeah user level dimensions
and
teras of bid requests being processed
every day so the data is pretty huge
so the business use case so as i said
we'll focus mostly on the advertiser
side
and basically there is some kind of a
sales funnel
as you can see cpm cpc cpa
where the more deep you are in this
sales funnel the more expensive that is
and basically today we'll focus on cpc
which is for our use case the most
common one
so let's talk about cpc for one second
cpc stands for cost per click
and basically most of the users i
believe most of you as well
do not click on an ad when they see it
and payment is done basically
only when there is a click and most of
the algorithms in this space are about
ctr optimization click through rate as i
believe some of you may know
so a naive basic example given a
specific user
and given a model that knows something
about the attributes and something about
the user
he's he will try to fit a relevant ad
which will eventually get to a
prediction or a non-prediction event
and that is something that as a as a
name example of this
ctrl goes second main aspect of the
business
it's called real-time video rtb for
short and
in simple words is basically some kind
of a competition between
uh some advertisers specific advertisers
who are willing to
bid based on a user's behavior or some
kind of a user's attributes
or in a more more general term term
context
so given let's say i don't know the
purple bidder for example didn't want to
bid
on a specific user maybe because that
advertiser
advertisers advertise student loans for
example
and the users that just arrived at this
moment is aged 60
so it's like real time bidding as
opposed to that we have the blue and the
black bidders who actually want it to be
so it's really depend on the context
well now we'll describe some main
challenges that are bitter and
advertiser faces
and we'll briefly go through each of
them so we have user filtering add user
matching
and auction pricing which is the main
context for
today's session cool so user filtering
basically user filtering is like
answering the basic question of as a
bidder
do i want that user yes or no or that
context we can say so it really depends
and there are several considerations
that
that an advertiser should take in place
for example user history
what did this user do in the past um
timing
let's say now it's 3 a.m and the user is
like um
i don't know the advertisement is on a
restaurant and some pickup from a
restaurant but the restaurant is
currently closed something like that
so it might be irrelevant for the user
right
click fraud this user was fraudulent in
the past for
some reason legal limitations and there
are many in the industry as of
ios 14 gdpr etc so a lot of things to
take into
consideration second the
main let's call it challenge or that
bidder is facing is add user matching
in simple words basically we have tons
of advertisements
tons of users and we should match
between them
between both of them basically since
there are many ads each one of them has
its own behavior
for example targeting pricing etc
and the goal here the main goal is to
balance between exploration and
exploitation of trends
and eventually this is something that
can be formulated as a recommendation
system
by the way taboola and some other cool
companies are doing
such things our main challenge
which will focus on today's session is
auction pricing
the main question here is basically how
much to bid
and how much to bid is a question on i'm
talking about the rtb auction
it's a question which we can split to uh
first one is how much to bid
given that specific user that specific
context
and the second one is how much to bid
given the competition that i'm currently
in
so for example um we have five bidders
in this slide
four of them bid one two three dollar
four dollars accordingly
and the fifth one is like uh don't know
how much to read so
like one example can be if will bid with
10 he'll probably win right
but if we'll beat with the five he'll
win as well so
the main goal here is basically to
minimize
the amount that we put on bids however
we want to maximize of course the number
of times we will win in the auction
so now we'll describe some approaches
for pricing which are basically
part of this industry so first one
the manual way as known as the account
manager way
an account measure basically can set
prices um
manually so for example let's set prices
0 to 10 to users from israel
price is 10 to 20 users from us etc
very common in the industry not scalable
at all
bad way not the data way we can say
second method is called with some kind
of a propensity model
and basically that means we can train
some kind of a binary classifier
binary classifier can be anything you
know xg boost logistic regression neural
network etc
given that we want to predict some kind
of uh let's say probability of click
for example in our use case so we get
that probability
we can multiply that probability with
some kind of a configuration information
that we have
such as the maximum allowed bid and we
can beat based on that price
so numeric example p we got some kind of
a
probability of click on a given user 0.7
the maximum allowed bid five bit price
will be 3.5 accordingly
however there is something um that
bothers with this method
uh it is that this method assumes that
there is some kind of a linear
relationship between the win the bid
price and the probability and what do i
mean by that
so this graph basically presents this
phenomena as long as we
increase the price that's what we expect
using this model
as long as we increase the price we will
we'll we'll actually think that the
probabilities of win
is going to be higher and higher in a
linear rate
like if will bid sorry but you do have
experiment coordination
questions in the end yeah sure i'll
answer it no thanks
um so basically we do think that there
is a linear rate
um of increasing the price and
increasing the probability of win
however in reality it's not like that
let's say given some kind of a context
for example um
banner so banner prices for those who
know
are actually pretty low let's say zero
to two for example
so within this range of zero to two you
might have um
a probably let's say um ads types that
are not banner you might have like a
very low amount of probability of
winning
and then you have this spike which
actually describes that
prices from that range beyond you have a
very high amount of probability
of winning so eventually you won't have
a real linear uh
relationship between the price and the
probability of fling
the third and the main method which
we'll describe today is called multi-arm
bandit and basically
it is a strategy or a method of choosing
an individual choosing trying to choose
from a set of options so what do i mean
by that
the classic handbook example is when a
gambler gets into a casino
and trying to pull relevant arms
that might maximize his reward and what
he's willing to get is eventually he
would like to maximize his reward given
the fact that
there are many slots relevant but each
one of them is with some kind of an
unknown distribution
basically this method can work well
however it's
it's not taking into consideration uh
the context and what do i mean by
context again
users features for example geo users age
and some other cool parameters that we
can take use
so given let's say two users each one of
them
is trying to i don't know one from us
one from uk eventually both of them will
get
the same the same prediction because
we're not
dealing with like the same uh set of
where we are dealing with the same
parameters for each of them
and eventually this is this is a type of
a problem uh that we're
trying to balance between exploration
and exploitation
we're exploring can be you know try to
pull whatever arm you have and
exploiting is actually
given that we know some information
about about arms
we can use and pull only these arms in
order to maximize our reward
here comes in place contextual bandits
cool so contextual bandits basically
as a classic example as a classic
handbook example
contextual bandit is relevant for
categorical variables so
for example we want to show the user ads
from
with a different different colors so we
have a green color
purple blue and black and each one of
them will produce some kind of a
probability
now each of these arms actually
represents a model so for example um
logistic regression each one of them
logistic regression
exi boost neural network etc and this
probability
will be based on our um on our goal
and for example in the classic handbook
example our goal is to
show the user the ad that you will be
mostly likely to click on
and now what's the main difference is
basically that we have the context
and the context is a set of features
that are relevant to the user
so for example context can be user geo
ad type
for example banner user age and some
other parameters that are relevant
each one of them is get as an input i
mean as some kind of a vector each one
of them is getting as an input to the
model and the model will produce us some
kind of
probability that user will be likely to
click on the ad
then we get some kind of a feedback
let's say one in case we had one
um we had meaning that the user had
click on the ad
and zero otherwise and using that
feedback we will
update our beliefs and by updating our
beliefs i mean that there are several
strategies such as thompson sampling
for those who know epsilon greedy beyond
of this scope
but then once we update our beliefs we
actually can retrain
the whole process again and again what
actually we managed to do
is taking this this attitude
into prices into into ordinal variables
and what do you mean by that
so ordinal variables are like for
example bit price now each model
represents a bin of prices or a price
so one for example stands for prices
between zero to two
three prices two to four and you get the
point
now given a context that will be
inserted into each of the models
we'll get some kind of a probability and
now our objective is a bit different
because we actually want to make sure
that
we win and we win the auction and that's
like our objective so it's like
again some kind of a classification
problem with whether whether we won
or lost the auction but using some other
um
objective here we get the feedback one
in case we want and we
retrain the model following that update
again and again
basically nothing using this method
nothing pres
prevents the model from bidding like the
highest bit so like in
in that case we won with the price of
seven
nothing prevents uh from using seven and
again again and again and this i think
it's something critical because it's
actually the place for creativity and
what do you mean by that
there are several strategies that we
tried weren't in any of the
let's call it papers and like tutorials
that we
read about and there are several um
methods they think that
each each everyone can try and actually
be much smarter in terms of
not beating the highest because if will
bid just the high price again again a
high price again again
what will happen is that we'll end our
budget very very fast
so method number one of preventing this
phenomena can be using some kind of a
custom reward function
and method number two is applying some
kind of an aggregation strategy and
we'll work them through
now cool custom revolved
so custom reward function basically
means that
we're using the the old let's call it
the old um
schema we're just updating the relevant
model
that had the one or that had been used
during the last auction so in case of
winning or losing the auction we will
update that particular model
using custom reward we basically use
some kind of a mutual information that
is passing by
between the the bandits or the models
because for example in the case of
ordinal variables
we have let's say five so if we had one
with five
maybe in the next iteration in the next
auction we want to try out
three maybe we can win but with a
cheaper price as opposed to that
if we had lost with five we'll probably
lost with the
going to lose with three and one
accordingly so we might
give them some kind of a reward or
feedback as well same goes with seven
or some other um arms
second method that one that you may try
is basically discarding this set of
probabilities or
as opposed to that injecting some kind
of a business logic
this is called aggregation strategy what
do you mean by that
there are several methods but for
example one yeah you'll see
in in the coding example in a bit but
basically you can define some kind of a
win
a desired win rate that um you're
willing to get
and using that win rate you can
re-estimate your probabilities that
are given based on the model's output
and we
retrain the model again and again you'll
see a coding example in a bit
cool let's say put it all together like
as an example just to make sure we're
clear
so let's say we have some kind of a
context the context can be a specific
request from a specific user
willing to see an ad at this moment
let's say it's ages 30 geo us and ad
type banner
then and this is something a bit
architectural but basically we have a
set of arms which can be calculated
let's say via some kind of a batch job
based on that context so it is known
based on our his
data let's say historical data
that the arms are being they are the
prices of
let's say banner in us are being
distributed between
one to six in this example so we can
like calculate relevant
arms accordingly and uh combining
combine them here together
then each one of them has its own
probability of winning the auction
based on our beliefs in our training
again and again
and we're using some kind of an
aggregation strategy we can generate
some
a bit price this bit price will
eventually compete within the rtb
auction
and then when we go to the rtb auction
we get some kind of a feedback a reward
accordingly which will be based on
whether we had not won or lost the
auction
then what will happen is that we'll need
to retrain our process again and again
using of course some kind of a custom
reward because we want to give a
feedback to
not only a specific arm but rather to
all of the arms that
got participated or even all of the arms
cool main takeaways so this is
this something that can be heard as some
kind of a cliche but basically
context matters a lot and you got to
know your data
and this is something that you can
achieve by doing a lot of
analysis like exploratory data analysis
in terms of what the context that
matters
um what's the best x let's call it
what is the most relevant parameters for
you this also can be achieved of course
by feature selection
which there are several methods that you
can use and i'll see you'll see a slide
in a bit
second thing is that ordinal arms offer
more feedback
this is something that is as opposed to
categorical variables
we can use this multiple updates or
custom reward that we implemented
that helped us a lot and third thing i
think is the
creativity point so you can use the
custom reward function aggregation
strategy and i believe that there are
more
because the the problem is pricing is
now getting uh let's call it more
popular so
definitely a lot of more room for uh
creativity
cool last slide basically this slide
shows um i'm not going to like to
let's deep dive into but basically the
x-axis is the number of iterations we
tried
within some kind of experiment the
y-axis stands for our loss function in
our case it was mae min absolute error
basically what we want what i want to
show here is that the context size
really matters it's not that as long as
you add more context
uh let's say context size equals two is
uh device os one hot encoded
ios one uh android zero etc and
so it's not as long as as you add the
more context
the error is going to be lower however
context really helps as opposed to
no context at all now you'll have a
short coding example by uri and then
we'll have some time for q a
okay so as daniel mentioned unlike
the classical multi-unbandit we have
multiple
inputs every time we want with five
dollars we also update
for example seven nine etc because
obviously we would have won also with
higher prices
i wanted to share a real cool a pipey
model
called contextual bandits by
a guy named david cortez but it's
actually very well maintained
and it's actually solved all the
problems we had
we wanted to build a framework that can
train the contextual bandits
for any sklm module and we wanted
our models to have a predict proper
function for predict probability
and to have a partial fit and we
even started to implement it and then we
discovered that someone else
peters do it and it's actually a great
product so
i highly recommend using it for
contextual bandits
uh this library actually supports both
online learning
and contextual bandits for offline
learning we are
obviously more interested in the online
model
and let's see a very short demo
and for privacy purposes it will be on
simulated data but i can assure you that
it works
just as well on fiber's real data
okay so what you need in order to use
this library
is to have a model any kind of model
that has the partial fit
meaning that i can train it
incrementally
and that it can predict the probability
okay so there are several models
and neural nets are one class of them
here we use logistic regression just a
technical note
the different implementation of logistic
regression does not have
a partial fit but you can use energies
of regression
via the sgd class classifier with the
logistic loss
so same model different class name
okay so in order to test whether the
models are learning we try to simulate
the data
and here we simulated prices according
to this distribution
meaning that users from germany that are
using an android device
would be approximately five four dollars
we also added some noise in order to
make it
more realistic and for example ios users
from
the us would be
worth is give or take nine dollars
so we randomized data according to this
uh joint
distribution and we wanted to see
how quick does our model pick that up
okay so we synthesize the data
and very conveniently we have a data
frame
already one hot encoded with random data
according to that distribution
now a good moment to notice the
differences between
reinforcement learning contextual
bandits and supervised learning
in supervised learnings we have x and y
the features and the targets
and in contextual bandits reinforcement
learning
we have the features the action that
we're going to take the action going to
be
for example being five dollars or be ten
dollars
and the reward the reward is what that
action actually
uh how much money we pocketed in
okay so the contextual bandits library
uses this notation
instead of x and y x r and a
daniel mentioned the aggregation
strategy
and our aggregation strategy is pretty
simple but it took us
a lot of time to think about it which is
essentially
if you are going to win 100 of the times
you're paying too much if you're going
to win zero percent of the times
you're not bidding enough so we have an
additional hyper parameter
which is the amount the percentage of
time we want to win
and we try to optimize for that number
so
the closer a model is to our desired win
rate
the more likely we are going to select
it
so we used some function it doesn't
really matter
that gets a higher as we get closer to
our desired wind rate
here it's a a fraction of
uh one over the difference between the
probability and the desired wind rate
and some kind of exponential just for
the fun of it
but as long as the function increases
as we are closer to the desired winrate
the more likely
we are going to select that arm and we
essentially
patched the predict proper function
of the original sgd classifier
using this patch we can run the library
as is
with our domain knowledge
so for this example we assume that the
bid is between 0
and ten dollars and our resolution is a
one cent so we have one thousand buckets
just for our demonstration purposes
and we simulate a real auction
so this is the regret in
contextual bandits we measure the
optimal price
minus the price that we build it doesn't
look that good
when you look at it like that but it's
worth mentioning that this is a
stochastic process
so we need some kind of smoothing in
order to see the underlying trend
and once you smooth it a bit you can see
that actually the regret does decline
and unfortunately it also increases in
this specific uh
execution but you can see that the model
does learn
something so we have
another we we know how we sample the
data and you know we know the true
distribution
let's see if the model picked it up
so for users with from the us
using an android device the actual bid
is supposed to be
seven and our bandits bid
seven point something 7.2 and as you can
see it's
relatively close so the model did learn
and did converge
to the true distribution of the data
now the question is how does the context
matter do i really need
those two features maybe i can use only
one of them so we demonstrated here
that when we use only one feature the
results are significantly worse
for example the overall regret for
the two this context of size 2
is a 0.54
and for any individual feature
the overall regret is much higher
but we can see for example that the
prices are
actually not that accurate so the model
really
could not pick up the true distribution
uh with uh with an incomplete context
okay so that's it um any questions
[Music]
and collaborate filter
it's multi-unbanded with collaborative
filters that you make some
kind of context which can collaborate
filter and
kind of merge it i think that the main
takeaway here is the
ordinal relations because in multi-on
bandits you don't have the relations
between
different colors and here you can
actually know you will learn faster
because you have you need less input
yeah collaborative
what does it mean i don't know you but i
know your brother
so maybe i can use the information from
your brother so
here like you did then like you did your
optimization or sort of interpretation
and your brother but they can
but then i can do that use this this
context about you and i'll be in a
better
place if i won't do that but unlike
collaborative filtering
we have another um information
we have the ordinal so for example i
can't
say which one is bigger or better but i
can't say that
five dollars is less than six
could you go back to the learning
process
there's two graphs
yeah there's uh first the first one
yeah so this is the uh
you start uh
can you can you repeat this
so this is always positive and this is
the difference between the actual bid
and the bit of the bandage a bit so it's
it's the absolute value of the okay
[Music]
any other questions maybe to the end
but you mentioned you're trying to
maximize the
winnings given a certain budget so did
you consider some kind of knapsack
formulation because it's kind of
two different objectives really
so we did try other models and we also
tried other bandit formulations for the
gamma exponential model we tried to
model
the price as a continuous variable and
not it is an ordinal
it did not perform as well as
this formulation
that's a great question and i don't have
an answer with it it's
it's trial and error
yeah so uh what was a bit weird for me
you said you were trying to
reach a certain win rate or something
for that which is it doesn't sound like
a really your goal here right your goal
here is
to maximize your revenue eventually you
can't can't you just formalize that in
the sense of
you know what's my my gain if i win
times i don't know probability of the
user clicking or whatever
yes it's like right so you can't just
this way reach sort of the goal function
so that's a good point so what else
i mentioned is that we are not we're not
optimizing here for the objective of
amount of money in the bank right we are
optimizing for a win rate and
it's actually we had a slide for that
so the phenomena we encountered is that
the probability of win is very
it's very hard to predict so essentially
the bandits are learning
this curve so i'm trying to fix the
probability of wind without win rate
and the bandits learn the approximate
the appropriate
price it really depends on other
business logic down the line a few years
ago
i was working in a firm that we tried to
find this
sweet point that jumping point and
thus using it
helpful so i guess
there are also other solutions to try
and model the scale but maybe you can
combine
because basically what you try to
optimize is not
say something for a philosophy reason
you want to
so there's also a lot of work a lot of
additional work to be done this is the
only one aspect of
yeah one last question please so
for this chart why isn't like a regular
calibration work
um
so it's it's a great question so the
question was why
don't we use like regular calibrations
platform sklearn
and my only answer is empirical it
didn't work just as well as our
contextual bandit framing okay so thank
[Applause]
you